horrific news coming out of nigeria
where muslims are slaughtering
christians
by the thousands a news agency in west
african country reports
islamic jihadists have butchered nearly
3 500
christians in the past year they've
murdered 250 christ followers just since
may
this tragedy is largely ignored by the
international community
the head of jihad watches robert spencer
tells church militant mainstream media
is partly to blame the establishment
media
follows a narrative that muslims are
always in and every case victims
and christians are always and in every
case oppressors
but the idea that this could be muslims
perpetrating this and christians being
the victim does not fit the
establishment media paradigm and so it's
ignored
catholic bishops in the region have
urged the government to intervene
nearly half of nigeria's population is
christian